[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
well it isn't every day that i get to
interview a friend a collaborator
a brilliant
young first-time author
a new postdoc a post-doctoral fellow and
really just one of the uh one of my
favorite people that i get to
collaborate with and that
now we can get to learn from and you can
get to learn from out there in the world
because she is the author
of this wonderful new book from a first
person perspective from a neutrino and
that's none other than eve
i hope i always hope i pronounced it
correctly eve did i do okay you did you
did great
and it's illustrated by another uh a
little bit unusual name uh to pronounce
the ilsa lemesis
yeah right awesome good all right well
that's the end of the interview i
dropped the mic
brian has a win that's all that matters
no i'm just kidding um eve it's such a
pleasure to talk to you
you and i have been friends since we
began collaborating i've tried
unsuccessfully at least three times to
get you to come to uc san diego but i'm
not bitter i'm not bitter at all
but now you're here virtually back again
you'll be back hopefully this summer for
our face-to-face meeting for the simon's
observatory where eve works tirelessly
on all things experimental
and normally eve we have on theorists
you know we have people like
neil degrasse tyson michio kaku
brian green hopefully not too long from
now
we've had 11 nobel prize winners but
many of them are theoretically inclined
you are an experimentalist what does an
experimental astrophysicist do
we turn a lot of allen keys
so many allen keys first of all thank
you so much for having me on um it's
such a pleasure and a real honor to be
amongst such esteemed guests oh my
goodness
so thank you so much first of all second
of all we get to build all of the
equipment that is needed to check all of
those theorists wonderful theories
because if we don't turn our allen keys
there will be no way to check if people
are right about what they come up with
to describe our universe so i've been
involved in developing these cryogenic
cameras for these telescopes that are at
least the ones that we work on for the
simon's observatory and that i work on
for the atacama cosmology telescope and
for seacat observatory all down in the
atacama desert in chile and when i say
camera i think a lot of people think of
obviously the cameras that you hold up
and and take selfies with and and things
like that but these instruments are
practically room filling or sometimes
high bay filling gigantic
cans of coldness that you don't
necessarily think of as being cameras
before you get to to know them and
something else that i didn't find
intuitive when i first started is the
window through which the light from the
telescope shines in to eventually be
filtered and focused with lenses onto
the detectors the pixels of our cameras
those windows are actually not clear to
your visual site because we're looking
at these microwave wavelengths these are
the things that we want to measure when
we're looking at the cosmic microwave
background and um it's funny to me to
have walked into a lab and be like but
how can how can we see through that
because that's not that's not even a
clear window um so working in
wavelengths that you're not necessarily
familiar with with cameras at a much
larger scale than we're familiar with in
our our daily lives but it's it's a lot
of fun yeah and you do stuff very low
temperature and we'll get into that what
you do on a daily basis
but first we have to acknowledge the
fact that we are speaking on a frigid
day here in san diego you are at cornell
university and that is in ithaca uh
where my origin story almost began had i
gotten accepted to cornell the two times
i applied but didn't get in but anyway
we're not gonna talk about that uh but
instead you are uh have been there for
for quite some time since you're an
undergraduate now you're a postdoctoral
fellow moving to princeton as i
understand it in the fall and everyone
should follow eve on twitter we'll put a
link to all of her social media accounts
because she does so much outreach etc
but first of all ithaca is it
warmer or colder san diego is about 60
degrees right now it's a frigid february
day as we're speaking what's the
temperature right now and like that um
it's a little bit colder it's uh not
quite above freezing yet it's around 30
degrees right now fahrenheit about half
the temperature now when we
are building these instruments you
talked about these big you know vacuum
chambers etc um how much of what you do
is as technical you know turning the
allen keys um kind of um as a technician
might and no disrespect to technicians i
love them i am one but um but how much
of that is driven your your career is
driven by that versus your curiosity to
understand the theoretical the
observational underpinnings of our
universe what's the breakdown that you
maintain well part of why i joined my
knee max group at cornell for graduate
school is because i was so interested in
trying to go down every potential avenue
i could in cosmology so i wanted to do
the analysis portion i wanted to look at
the maps that we've generated with these
telescopes already and i wanted to not
just use and work on equipment insurance
crews but i wanted to design the
equipment too
and i was it was a real gift to be able
to be to be involved in all of the above
so i have been designing the first light
instrumentation for ccap prime
and i've also been working with maps
that have already been generated by
others hard design and
equipment development work for the
autocoma cosmology telescope looking at
maps of the cosmic microwave background
and looking at i like to call the bones
of our universe shining the cmb through
these large structures these galaxy
clusters the largest gravitationally
bound objects in our universe and
learning about these structures and how
our universe has evolved by using maps
of the cmb
in addition to doing all the cryogenics
day-to-day in the lab
some of what you do i think of as uh as
akin to kind of like an archaeologist an
explorer you know and they have to build
their own tools and then they have to
travel to these exotic locations how
much of that you know try to
walk through your kind of elevator pitch
to a young lady young man out there is
maybe interested in science cosmology
specifically
why should he or she become a an
experimental cosmologist like yourself
oh gosh well i would say first of all
that you're adding in extra activities
to the thinking about fundamental
physics so you can think about the
theory and also participate heavily in
analysis and theory work and you can
write all of the code that you want to
write um in addition to understanding
all of these really interesting physical
phenomena down here in earth in the
laboratory so the principles and
properties of superconducting devices
that allow us to make these measurements
in the first place
and the sheer diversity of your daily
work when you're involved in the
experiment side of things is really
compelling if you're the kind of person
who doesn't like to sit still in your
chair
all day every day and stare at a glowing
box forever this is much more up your
alley because i get to stand up and walk
to the lab and look at something
physical and then go back to my computer
and look at the glowing box again for
many hours
and i really thrive on that diversity
and i think a lot of people would find
it really entertaining and interesting
how much variety is in a daily life as
an experimentalist
yeah and getting the sense of progress
you know when you're when you're
lost in a paper that could take years to
write or something like that or or some
some for as i understand what theorists
do and and some of my best friends are
theorists so you know i i should i don't
talk too negatively about them but um
but it could take years to get you know
one equation even vetted whereas you
know in the lab we can walk you know
down and and feel like you actually made
some progress now of course we also have
setbacks and we have things that we have
to encounter as you know uh we have been
no stranger to setbacks and and
challenges in any project um what gets
you through those challenging moments
when you have a setback when you have
like this part it has nothing to do with
cosmology you ordered some part you know
from thor labs you're i think you should
be sponsored by thor labs because you're
like one of the best kind of um you know
uh uh you know kind of representatives
of them but anyway you're waiting for
this thing it's out of stock you know we
need this power amplifier and it's you
have to reboot the factory how do you
get through those challenging times
where everything's out of your control
and you have no influence over the
outcome as an experimentalist that
happens quite frequently how do you deal
with such instances
well when you say that it doesn't just
happen in experimental life but life in
general right this is a daily basis
thing um so first of all you try power
cycling of course and turning it on and
off again if that doesn't work then you
go home no um
what really what really does it first of
all is hopefully all of us have
experienced the opposite of that the
times where things do come through
when i was an undergraduate working on
my first ever cad design project for
this little interferometer it's a little
um parallel mirror translator that was
going to go on the
sofia telescope the stratospheric
observatory
for oh no i've lost the entire app for
infrared astronomy that's what it is yes
thank you
um on the fly literally um
seeing that come out of the machine shop
for the first time having never
submitted parts and they actually fit
together and it was actually the shape i
wanted and it actually did what i wanted
it to do
the thrill of that is always in my mind
and so i have things to look back on
former successes that i can look back on
and say okay
literally nothing is working this day
week or month or maybe a year if you're
having a very bad year
but things have worked before and you
have to have faith that things can work
again and
i think life comes in waves as does work
in the lab where you'll have successful
times
and you'll have the not so successful
times and it's it's a sheer product of
the not successful times that you have
any success in the first place at all so
it's almost a prerequisite so when
things are going poorly um it's kind of
like when you're climbing up a hill on
the bike you have to go up that hill in
order to go down the hill you have to go
through the difficult times where your
data doesn't make any sense and the
cable fell apart for the thousandth time
and you don't have time to solder it and
you have to anyway um you work through
those knowing that that is
uh that needed to happen to have your
success happen in the future
and you know the challenges as you say
you know happen inside and outside of
the laboratory but um in terms of like
what keeps you going on the most macro
level of all
describe to my audience what fascinates
you the most about the cosmos
specifically because you could be doing
you have a you're like liam neeson you
know you've got a particular set of
skills that are you know deadly no no
they're not dead but
um but you could be doing anything i
mean you're incredibly well-rounded
educated
um and uh and you have talents ranging
from computer programming statistical
data analysis machine learning and also
unique experience with low temperatures
as low as a fraction of a of a kelvin
that you can routinely do and it's a
very rare skill set what
caused you to turn this intellectual
capital specifically in this direction
what fascinates you the most about
cosmology
so when i was an undergraduate thinking
about what i would like to study i went
into college knowing i wanted to do
something with astronomy something with
space sciences i was always very
interested in space as one of the final
frontiers i either wanted to study space
or the brain because i thought that
those two were just enormous compelling
spaces that had so much wealth to be
discovered
and the more i learned about physics and
astronomy
cosmology was a way for me to be
intellectually greedy because it's
literally everything
at once
and what could be more compelling than
literally everything all at once
to think that i as this small creature
this meat machine that is on this little
space rock flying around in a
nondescript part of the galaxy um by
design right if it was too exciting here
we wouldn't be able to be life form so
it's actually quite boring
that i can look out and devote my
professional life to studying
the entire universe every day
that gets me out of bed
um i love thinking that i can contribute
in my small way to the knowledge base of
humankind
and if i'm not going to do that then i
would want to do something that helps
people personally
sometimes i do feel a little bit sad
that my efforts aren't going to a
tangible
putting you know a real smile on
people's faces and that's where my
educational activities come into play i
feel like i can use what i'm doing to
try to push along our our little bubble
of human knowledge i don't know if
you've seen that graphic of a phd which
is like this is enormous and discipline
and then you're just carving out the
tiniest little poking out into your
knowledge sphere so not only am i
working on that on a very compelling
topic um but that i could also translate
that into helping other people
discover that not only could they go
into stem fields or go into physics or
go into something like what i'm doing
but simply that
big challenging
topics that are intimidating
are fields in which people can
go and contribute to and in fact are
needed in and
society needs everybody to feel like
they can access what they want to access
and give what they can give so that's my
my way of trying to translate the you
know the oh i'm studying the whole
cosmos thing into like i'm helping
people
that's what i'd like to see
and i talked uh recently with another
author his name is uh grant lewis he's
written a bunch of books and his latest
book is about uh it's called where did
the universe come from it's written by a
collaborator i think chris corey they
wrote these books astrophysics for
babies and all sorts of other books that
i love and my babies love but um but he
said the neutrino is the most
interesting object in the universe and
now
uh and i don't know when that interview
will come out relative to yours because
today one of the main goals that i have
is to expose as many people as i can to
uh to this book and whether you've
watched or not past episodes you know
one of my favorite things to do
is a segment that i call
judging books by their covers
and that's when we do what you're never
supposed to do which is to judge a book
by its cover but it was a first-time
author like you or when i wrote my first
book um what else can you judge a book
by you know you see it you know you get
some word of mouth perhaps
but talk to me about this book and it's
published by mit kids press which is a
delightful imprint and i've been been
grateful to get to know some of the
folks at mit
press um but this is my first children's
book
that i featured on the show
now for my audience to play judging
books by their covers what is the origin
of the title and what are these
mysterious whimsical characters on the
cover meant to represent
so i think
the big news story here is we've
discovered that neutrinos are fuzzy cute
little creatures
so so i'm a neutrino came about after
one of my particle physics classes in
graduate school where i had just joined
mike nemac's group and i was thinking
about these big questions we can address
with cosmology and specifically what big
questions i could be tackling with my
research
and one of the things that surprised me
was that we can use the cosmic microwave
background to use the entire universe as
a laboratory for particle physics which
excited me because i was also interested
in particle physics when i was an
undergrad thinking about what i could do
in grad school so i'm like i can do both
that's fantastic and so we really can
use the cmb and specifically the
structures that the cmb is backlighting
to learn about how the universe evolved
over time and one of the
sneaky things that neutrinos got up to
early in the universe's history is that
they took some of the mass that's in the
whole mass budget of the universe and
just flew around with it and they didn't
cluster down like the rest of the
friendly matter down into these
gravitational wells instead they just
kind of flew away um like little mass
bandits and so they washed out some of
the large-scale structure of the
universe so as i was learning about the
physics behind these little particles
that took the mass away
i was really compelled by the notion
that we are just learning about these
neutrinos pretty recently they weren't
originally understood to have mass at
all and it was only this odd behavior
that they display with their oscillation
meaning at one point you pick up
neutrino up and you say oh that's an
electroneutrino and a little while later
down the road as it's flying around this
little mass you pick it up and oh now
it's a town neutrino and um they are
very curious little creatures um so my
whole life i've always just written down
poems that's just a feature of me is
i'll get hit in the head with a poem and
just write it all down so i got hit in
the head of the poem after one of my
particle physics classes and just wrote
down a poem and started with hi i'm a
neutrino
and i am so small that matter to me
barely matters at all
and i sent it to my mom
because i sent her all my poems
and she said wait this would be a great
children's book
um she's also in the publishing industry
she's a professional artist and her name
is elsa lemus she's uh the illustrator
of i'm a neutrino and so we started
working on this project together and she
came up with this this cute concept of
these little fuzzy neutrino friends
that i would not have thought of because
i think most particles are depicted as
little spheres
but they don't have to be spheres we're
not going to be able to take a picture
of them and we're not going to be able
to see them and they can be fuzzy if we
want them to be fuzzy so that's what we
did and this cover depicts a whole bunch
of colorful flying neutrinos um in the
swirling background that i really enjoy
because it's uh it's space but it's
abstract space and i think that the
cover joins the tiny with the very large
yeah to me it's kind of evocative of the
uh the other moniker that these
particles have which are ghostly
particles uh why are they called ghostly
particles
so we don't interact with neutrinos very
often um these little and i almost want
to call them creatures when i'm looking
at them on the page because they're sort
of animalistic
we can make them into creatures in our
minds but these particles don't interact
electromagnetically which is how we're
looking at each other right now and how
we interact with a lot of the world
they're also they have a tiny tiny mass
and they only interact through the force
of gravity and through the weak force
and although they're one of the most
numerous particles in the entire
universe they're streaming through us
all the time and we just can't feel them
can't see them they're harmless they
don't interact with ourselves they only
the weak force only interacts at very
small distances and they do not bother
us and we don't see them so they're
their ghostly little friends flying
through us constantly
or
maybe we know what they feel like we
just are completely immune to it because
it's happening all the time no but we
can't we can't actually feel them but
that's another great because we wouldn't
know because it's always happening
now i i happen to have access to some
children and uh they are on loan no
they're they're on loan from from heaven
uh but uh but actually they
really end up into this book so i would
say the target audience for at least an
informal survey of my household uh
ranges from about seven years old at the
younger age all the way up to 12 perhaps
on the upper age and maybe there's no
limit because i actually think it
appealed to me
uh because the illustrations are so
whimsical uh and your commentary your
poems is so so delightful and it's
evocative and it kind of reminded me of
a fellow cornelian i think is how you
say it uh and that's this guy carl sagan
so carl sagan had many many uh aphorisms
and and and great contributions both in
science
and hardcore science like uh you
practice and and also in communication
to the public um and for that i think he
deservedly gets a lot of great attention
but it didn't come naturally and he
actually got a lot of criticism and i
don't know if you know this but he was
not
elected and inducted into the national
academy of sciences
even though he made tremendous strides
we know him because a billion people at
the time saw his cosmos series but he
was also a phenomenal science he was
scientists he was one of the pioneers of
what we call astrobiology and what are
called extremophiles as well as being
you know a world-class planetary
scientist and working for nasa design
and one of the things he did was
was command the voyager 1 spacecraft on
valentine's day 1990 to take a picture
of the earth and it's called the pale
blue dot and we can put the poem up here
and it's really evocative
but
in so doing you know he he took a lot of
risks and i'm wondering um you know when
he was criticized he heard things like a
serious scientist doesn't do such things
as and nowadays he'd have a podcast like
me and he'd get criticism from his
department chair for spending time on
non-scientific related things um i do do
some other things as you know but uh
a real scientist should do but
um
how did
you overcome the barrier that most of my
colleagues will say as to why they don't
outreach as much to the public and that
is i'm not good at it and it's hard for
me how do you overcome that personally
so the reason i'm hesitating to answer
that is because i think
it's been the opposite for me when i
first started studying physics
that was hard for me that was something
to really overcome
i needed to work very hard to
understand the upper level courses that
came more naturally to my peers whereas
i've always been
excited to communicate about whatever it
is that i'm doing
i worked in my local library running
children's summer programs for six years
in middle and high school
and
really any topic that i pursue i love to
communicate so i think i would approach
the answer to that kind of in the flip
side because for me it was very hard to
learn to do the math that's required for
my physics courses and how did i get
good at that well
practice right you just need to do it
and
there are
moments in life when you start a new
skill
that
there's a suffering that needs to occur
for you to get good at anything that
you're trying to do um
that initial feeling of discomfort of
i'm out of my comfort zone or i don't
know if i should be doing this i don't
know if this is for me
um
you look to your left you look to the
right everybody else is seeming to do
great and you're just kind of
floundering
the imposters but that feeling i've
now been able to associate with that's
that's awesome that's day one that means
you have so much you can learn and so
far to grow
um when i don't have that feeling i get
a little concerned because i feel like
okay well i'm not learning any new
skills i'm stagnant at this point i want
to feel uncomfortable again
so if you can lean into that discomfort
and keep practicing whatever it is
that's difficult for you
um that will you'll get better
you're just you're going to get better
because the more you do something the
easier it gets and as long as you think
it's worthwhile i think that's the key
you need to find it to be worthwhile you
can't have everybody breathing down your
neck saying this is stupid why are you
out reaching with the public um but i i
hope that that has been changing in
departments and we're seeing the merit
of this
well one thing you know that you tweet
about write about and particle bytes and
other things that you work on um is
representation in physics issues of
equity diversity etc um and you do so in
a very um ecumenical way perhaps is
right where you're not um you know
chastising but you're i think you're
you're an optimist you are encouraging
uh um uh folks to get into it
undoubtedly uh i would prepare myself if
i were you i'm not being patronizing in
any way but i think you're gonna be a
lot of parents that are going to ask you
first of all eve how do i get my kid boy
or girl interested in this in science
stem is the future of the human race but
then from a lot of women they might say
or about parents of young of young girls
they might say how do i encourage
especially my my daughter uh to get
involved in science as you did so do you
have any i don't say like tips tricks
and hacks you know one weird trick to
get a phd in astrophysics from an ivy
league no no but but um how uh and it
sounds like you weren't like the you
know perfect sat score perfect gre score
person neither was i obviously but but
um but i think you know there's this
notion that you have to do that but how
would you recommend not necessarily what
what did you experience but what would
you recommend to these many you know
thousands and tens of thousands of
parents and a lot of young people that
are listening to this podcast as well
what's what's some of the um
ideas that you have to promote both
growth of stem for young people in
general but also for women specifically
yeah
so
my definition of equality will be
not when we achieve a certain quota in
every field or that we get
all women interested in stem i think
it's more along the lines of i want
every child to feel like
whatever they want to do whatever
they're interested in they can have
access to learn about
equally you can learn about any topic
you're interested in you're not being
held back from any topic specifically
and feel that there's a path forward and
a belonging for them in that field
so i'm very excited about getting women
into stem but i am overall most excited
about getting any child into any field
that they want to contribute to because
that to me is true equality of access
for stem specifically i think a few
barriers are in place and the parents
who are going to be coming to me and
asking me what they can do for their
kids are already doing great i would say
because
many many more parents don't even know
that this is available
or are pooh-poohing it to their kids
actively i was actively dis incentivized
from my family actually to go into
physics i'm from a family of musicians
i'm
one of the only scientists and i was
actively encouraged to not go into a
field that was so incredibly boring
so there are parents out there who are
saying don't study that that sounds so
dull and terrible and you i want you to
be a charismatic
young person
so the parents who are already
interested in this and are are buying
this book for their kids are already
doing fantastic um
for young people looking to get into
this field specifically
i think
part of what i'm trying to do with this
book is convey information about what
experimental life is actually like i
think there's just a knowledge gap
between
early education and active modern
research that even the undergraduate
students at cornell in our own labs
don't know for example that graduate
students receive stipends they don't
need to take out extensive student loans
to get a phd this is something that is
not widely known you do not have to be
rich to get a phd like you need to take
out loans for med school or for law
school um i come from a family that
could not have taken out loans for those
types of degrees and i couldn't have
done i couldn't have been here um if it
wasn't for that and i think this
knowledge needs to be conveyed
so um
anybody with a keyboard and an internet
connection i highly recommend spending
some time to look at you know the
nitty-gritty like can i afford it
where will i go
what am i going to be working on and
that's what i want to
start to provide some clues for for the
very youngest children out there because
it starts early and you need to know
what paths are available for you to even
take before you take them
yes very good so now we mentioned
earlier that no path to the heavens is
direct and and straight it always comes
with challenges
and i wonder you know if part of the you
know bias that we have
and seeing you know everybody as either
einstein or nothing is that we don't
talk about the setbacks the challenges
as much and i wonder you know if you'd
be willing to kind of you know talk
about the some of the experiences that
you had my advisor peter timby past
guest on the show uh everyone always
accusing me of name dropping oh you're
just name dropping neil degrasse well no
i'll also name drop peter timby uh who's
got zero social media
uh but um but i want to ask you he used
to tell me
that if you don't consider quitting
graduate school at least once maybe once
a year maybe he was trying to encourage
me to leave i don't know but um but if
you don't you know think about leaving
at least once um then you're not really
gonna getting the full experience of
being a student talk about like a
challenge a low point perhaps that you
fought through and this kind of
dovetails with one of our uh final
closing questions that we'll get to in
in a few minutes but uh but tell me eve
was there a challenge that you are
particularly
interested in sharing such that it might
be a teachable experience for those
students graduate students of which
there are many many many that listen to
this podcast
um yes
i'd like to share i think the early
story of my health challenge and how i
ended up transferring graduate schools
early on in my career and this isn't
something that i talk about a lot
because it is a bit personal with health
struggles but i think it's important to
talk about this type of struggle
because there are so many health
challenges out there but also because
there are just so many challenges out
there and people don't hear about the
way things can go wrong in graduate
careers
as much as you hear about the typical
stories
so when i graduated from cornell as an
undergrad i went to caltech
to start my grad school career and i
have really severe asthma that reacts
terribly to air pollution
little did i know the los angeles area
has some of the worst air pollution in
the country and it got me pretty bad i
developed bronchitis within my first
semester and i had already had a history
of that um so it really took me down and
i ended up on some powerful
medication for that that gave me such
severe achilles tendonitis that i ended
up in a wheelchair
and the doctor advised me that i should
not spend a lot of time outside um
period and so i was in a wheelchair i
couldn't drive myself to
my lab anymore i really couldn't
get involved in classes or social life
or my work um i couldn't
be my best self i could barely be myself
at all because i couldn't walk to the
kitchen and i really faced a reckoning
at that point um of realizing i could
not continue in the area because you
need to walk to do experimental physics
so i ended up transferring schools and i
had a choice of a few schools to go to
but i chose cornell in large part
because of the diversity of cosmology
work that i could
undertake there and i am so happy that i
ended up doing that choice even though
it wasn't very traditional because it
landed me back at my undergrad
institution
where i mean still am as a post-doc
right so it's it's not traditional of a
course and i certainly had to question
whether my health was going to keep me
back from
attaining the things that i wanted to
attain the most and i really needed to
focus a lot on building my physical
health back up to do the things that i
wanted to do
and i think i chose to stay
because
my desire to contribute in the way that
i felt i could if i hadn't had these
challenges keeping me back
was so strong and i did not want to see
a limitation that i did not choose for
myself destroy my dreams as a person and
i am so glad that i had the i guess
determination to
try i didn't know if i was going to work
i needed to i couldn't stand long enough
for my toasters toast i needed to work
back up to walking i needed to work back
up to to doing this work
and talking about into the impossible if
i had seen where i am today and i just
completed actually last october my first
imperial century on the bike i i biked
100 miles
um
i would not have thought that was
possible
so i am
so glad that i persevered through that
now
this story is not to say that grad
school is the right choice for every
person um but it is to say that if you
are determined to do something and
you're facing a real hardship um that
might not be of your choosing um you
know if you're going through financial
troubles family troubles health troubles
and these things are keeping you from
what you want to do but there's a
glimmer there's a crack um you know that
that the line in the song that says
there's crack and everything and that's
how the light gets in as a cryogenicist
i say that's where we put aluminum tape
so the light doesn't get it anymore um
but there really is a crack in all
things and you can exploit that if you
are determined enough to take the next
step and the next step and just see what
happens and i always said that i'm going
to continue in physics until somebody
kicks me out um nobody kicked me out not
even myself
right
that's great um so then i think you know
one thing i i never like to do is to you
know summarize the book completely and
especially with like audiobooks now you
know people will listen to them and i i
don't want to give away kind of the
goods now this book is is a is a quick
read even for a young person but i think
it's it's quite deep but uh but i wonder
you know if you wouldn't mind maybe just
reading
or maybe one passage or something maybe
even the first couple lines and i'll
show the
pictures as you're reading um if you
don't mind uh or if not if you don't
want to cannibalize book sales no i mean
everyone should get this book that has a
young person or if they're just
interested in it so maybe you could pick
a line and then you'll read it and then
we'll open the show with you reading uh
from this wonderful book okay and you
have to tell me what your kids think of
it because i'm dying to hear you started
and then you never told me so i'll i'll
read i'll make the bargain with you
we'll get them to open the show with
their with their live reads and their
reviews they
they summarized it perfectly and they
kept saying about how these things are
they they prove that ghosts are real so
i think that just as i'm trying to get
them to go to bed eve thanks a lot you
know it's it's now they're terrified
about ghosts being now not those kind of
these kind of ghosts
so so pick a page and i'll show the
illustration as you talk but only one
page please
okay well i i can i start with the
beginning and then i'll go one more page
into it because i've already sold the
album okay
so it says hi i'm a neutrino and i am so
small that matter to me barely matters
at all
i am a particle like electrons and light
i can pass through you without stopping
my flight
i'm electrically neutral i don't have a
charge and with my small mass i don't
feel very large
well i love it it should be it is now
you know when when someone has a kid
now it's my go-to gift you know which
parents you know they'll either
appreciate that or like a 529 savings
bond um so
my kids love this book and uh the the
two that are able to read on their own
at least and they accurately summarized
it and now i think the most exciting
thing is that it really uh generates new
ideas for them so one of them was
talking about could you um
could you use neutrinos for energy
and um you know i i think it's important
because this book
you know one of the descriptions that
you know we get as authors uh rather
it's podcast host you know it's it's
they give you a little blurb from mit
kids press and they talk about how the
message of the of the book in part is to
inspire kids that they too can become
scientists so anything that evokes a
question or puzzle and maybe can't be
answered i mean that's the purpose of
grad school right um so i think that's
the highest in comium that you can get
that these kids are inspired to ask
questions and uh and maybe maybe it will
lead to
uh an interest in science and i think it
will definitely lead to an interest
inside maybe it'll lead to a career in
science and i i i'm just going to say
this um i don't need a response from you
if you don't want to but i think most
parents would be really thrilled if
their kids became scientists
i i don't think there's a parent that's
not like i absolutely don't want my kid
to be in stem or steam as they as they
sometimes add to it because this book
really is a work of steam so feel free
to respond you don't have to um but but
i think it's an it's an ideal lifestyle
the life that you and i have is one of
intellectual rigor and pursuit and
scholarship and i think that's the best
reason to do it we could be both doing
stuff that's more profitable but um but
we enjoy it right
yes and i i'm so excited to hear that
your kids are coming up with these
questions and that's why in the back of
this it's not just a poem but for every
image that accompanies the poem there's
a learn more section that talks about
the physics that is behind this so the
statement you know with my small mass i
don't feel very large like that's cool
but what does that really mean and you
flip to the back and you start learning
about it and then there are other
resources that the kids can dig into
more and learn about so i'm hoping that
this is a
a mild introduction through the you know
the nice pros you can just read it if
you want to or you can dig deeper into
what the experiments actually are
and for your point about the lifestyle
of a scientist and how kids
you know can get interested in this i
would i would say what is more childlike
than looking at something and asking why
right that's all the kids are scientists
every child is a scientist every baby
when they're watching an object falling
is a scientist in that mode they're a
physicist they're doing physics in their
mind um and so i feel very childlike a
lot of the time in the lab and in our
work where we get to
we'll play with these giant toys that we
get to put on these ridiculous
telescopes it's just like it's real life
legos right and it's legos with a
purpose and that purpose is to
investigate some of our biggest
questions that are now adult-sized
questions but we've been asking this all
along and i'm sure you two have stories
of being a little kid and coming up with
little sandbox experiments and stuff
growing up um so i'd say being a
scientist portable nuclear devices
being a scientist is um there's a lot of
play and the the intrinsic curiosity in
our discipline is childlike in in a
really positive way so
i'm really happy to be a scientist
yeah it's wonderful and of course you
know as parents know the ultimate
question after you get this chain of
wise you know why is the neutrino half
the lotus man why does the neutrino go
through all matter what is it the
ultimate question can only be answered
but the the final answer because i said
so
that's not maybe the most scientific
thing you can say but um but actually it
gave my one of my kids a chance to bring
out some of his astroparticle jokes and
i wonder if you've heard this um do you
know uh the the photon gets a lot more
attention than the neutrino until now
until now now the neutrino's gonna like
what's a photon uh but uh but the
neutrino oh one of my kids was like um
this is really fun he got really patient
do you know it's basically like a
neutron except it has almost no mass and
it behaves just like a neutron in fact
they wanted to call it a neutron and he
was just like getting into it is so
funny so passionate about it but then he
broke out his his astroparticle joke um
why don't uh photons
carry luggage do you know why
why does it have to do with it being not
very light
well no so photons don't carry luggage
because they're traveling light
feel free to use that
feel free to use it that's fantastic
it's almost as good as i had delilah
gates on over the summer last year and i
asked her do you know why um
uh black holes are so skinny and have
you heard of the black hole diet
and she said no and i said yeah you just
eat light
these are the dad jokes that mix with
extra particle jokes that now you can
use uh for your benefit okay eve we've
now reached a segment of this podcast
where we go into the impossible with the
thrilling three final questions let's
ready to go go go go
[Music]
i'm really breaking out all the
acoustics
and if you're just listening i'm pumping
my fists you can't see pumping well and
she has been to the gym she puts her
workouts on the twitter i always love
that it always makes me feel like a like
a real slob uh thank you eve for
inspiring uh us elderly uh senior
colleagues to get back to the gym and
rock climb you're a rock climber right i
do like climbing yes he's awesome we're
going to go in new jersey
oh um well i'm only going to be going to
princeton in the last year of my
fellowship so for now i'm going to keep
exploring the finger lakes so i don't
know but i'm sure that there you know
what i would love to do is get back into
aerial arts because i went to the circus
school here briefly and that was really
fun so i bet the princeton area has more
resources for aerial art stuff it
probably does
okay eve as you know we like to talk
about the deepest existential questions
on the show because i think as
scientists we have our own unique
perspective on the meaning the purpose
the value of different things about our
lives and so i like to share this
dimension of my um of my guests with my
audience so the first one has to do with
your future
uh you know 90 hundred years from now
and that's uh involves what's called an
ethical will it's not your monetary will
which as a you know grad student and
postdoc is probably replete with riches
and bitcoin and no i'm not assuming that
but i want to ask you when you reach the
age of 120 years old which is five
factorial as you know um when you get to
that biblical age of 120
what wisdom not material
bequeathment but what wisdom would you
hope to convey to those that come after
you
to stay out of la stay out of the lake i
told you san diego is nothing like l.a
yeah going back to to your gym comment
um a little bit i
i think that there is
so much marriage that
isn't highlighted very often but needs
to be in developing the foundations
required for these higher successes
your health your physical health your
environment
um
these things are required for you to do
anything that you want to do
and as a society
our collective health our environmental
health
not living in polluted places having
access to clean water um not being in a
war zone uh
having
ability to not have your mental space
taken up by where you're going to get
your next meal or how you're going to
manage your rent situation or your
household difficulties
focusing your efforts into helping each
other and helping your own self develop
a strong foundation
is the only way that you can start to do
the type of science that brings all of
your listeners to this podcast and the
type of higher level intellectual
pursuits that we can accomplish as a
society um we need to focus on the
basics that get us there in the first
place and it's easy to not go to the gym
it's easy to not clean your house it's
easy to try to focus on the and i i say
that speaking personally i i sometimes
you know skip these things um
it's really important to maintain uh not
just the trivial aspects of cleaning
your living room and doing your health
but from a societal aspect it's it's
easy to
issue
the smaller um
things in in in favor of the immediate
reward
but we really need to foster a healthy
society and a healthy self in order to
get where we want to go collectively and
individually
yes wonderful and the second question
also goes into the future but this one a
much further future a billion years into
the future and it's sort of based on
this movie 2001 a space odyssey where
there are these monoliths these kind of
menacing objects maybe their time
capsules maybe they're warnings maybe
they're just kind of like trophies or
something like that and
um and it really made me kind of think
about what would we
most want to encapsulate what humans
have learned about in your field which
is also my field but what would you put
on a billion-year-lasting time capsule
to tell
our future alien inhabitants about the
glories the wonders of what humankind
has accomplished in scientific
in the scientific realm
well this question is interesting
because as academics we publish our
research right and if the answer isn't
what you're publishing then why are you
publishing
right
um so in some part what i'm publishing
no it'll be it'll just be the archive
no
um
yeah jokes aside uh well first of all i
hope my research is somehow useful and
that's one exciting thing is that
realistically i'm not going to build a
billionaire monolith probably but but
realistically i will be leaving behind
the things that i am publishing and so
that's one nice part of what i do is i
feel like i am building a small tome of
of information that hopefully will help
future people
but on a larger scale for the whole
planet and such i'm not sure my
particular research is um
speaks for all of humankind for all of
history um
but i think i would probably do
something like an earth's black box
where
um i like to think about the fermi
paradox right which is
why having it be statistically likely
that there are intelligent life forms
out there that should have reached us by
now have we not heard from any and there
are a bunch of theories as to why that
might be
one of those theories is that maybe
civilizations destroy themselves before
they can make enough progress to get out
there and interface with other
civilizations
and i hope we're not going that way but
right now it doesn't look super great
for our planet and our longevity um
unless we change our perspectives and
our motivations as a society and and
really help this environment um so i
think i would encapsulate
everything
that happens um into a black box like
those on aircraft as they crash
i believe we don't crash it would be
great if we don't crash but if we do
crash um having a record of what
happened and how we got there and the
rich diversity of biological life on
this planet and all of the beautiful
things that we have around us to to
appreciate right now um i i draw a lot
of inspiration from the natural world
and i spend a lot of time outside um
both in my career and just my personal
life and i think writing or
encapsulating that somehow into this
black box everything that that was and
that might end um or not hopefully we'll
see
that would be useful for the
civilization that finds it because
clearly they're still kicking and i
wouldn't want them to encounter the same
problems that that we have and so if
they could learn something from our
experiences we might help with
intelligent life in the future so i'd
like a black box
okay that's wonderful just don't have it
be a cd-rom or something
yeah don't require yeah like an sd card
reader um and the last question now
instead of going into the near future
the far future is going to take us to
your past uh for you because you are uh
younger than the average uh guest on the
into the impossible podcast i'll only
ask you to go back say 10 years 15 years
um half your current age or
approximately thereof and i want to ask
you um along the lines of what arthur c
clarke said he said the only way of
determining the limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and i want to ask
you
what would you tell as advice to your
former self
to give her the courage to go as you
have gone into the impossible what
advice would you give to your former
self
you know
i love this explanation of your podcast
name and this is how i feel like all of
my life has been has been repeated steps
into the impossible um i was once well i
often climb large hills but um one of
the times i climbed a large hill i
thought to myself wow i'm approaching
this hill
i have no idea how i'm going to get up
the hill i cannot see a path up the hill
i don't even know if it's too steep if
i'm gonna like fall off the thing um but
you take one step and then the other one
becomes obvious and you take that step
and then another one becomes obvious and
you just continue and then you're up the
hill and you're like wow i didn't see
how i was gonna go up that hill um
that's how the past 10 or 15 years of my
life have gone you do one step with the
best of your abilities at the time um it
might be really small it might feel like
it has no impact on the next 10 years
you might not be able to see the path
forward whatsoever at all
and
little me and me now honestly has
trouble having faith in that next step
um
i think if i could go back and talk to
little me and be like you can find the
next one i promise
and it really is every step into the
impossible leads to another step into
the impossible until everything actually
was possible all along you just can't
see it um
and i yeah i would really appreciate
having just known like no you should
just keep stepping like
you got this
keep on going into the impossible i love
it that's beautiful eve well we've been
talking today with a
longtime friend but but first time
author
uh dr eve vavayakis who has written this
book with ilsa lemisis called i'm a
neutrino uh and it's a first person
perspective that gives kids an up-close
and personal introduction to both the um
the the beauty of science but also a
taste of what it feels like to ask
questions which as you've said it's
really the core of what it means to be a
scientist and to do as we recommend on
this channel my motto is abc
always be curious
and i think this book has the highest
praise
the testimonial from both me and my kids
who enjoyed it that this is such a
lovely contribution that will really
stoke the imaginative fires and keep the
curiosity alive
eve thank you so much for joining us on
this cool frosty late winter day in
ithaca may it warm up soon and may we
see each other again in person here in
san diego this summer uh if not before
thank you so much for having me brian
this has been wonderful
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you like this video check here for a
playlist that i created just for you
[Music]
[Music]
you